Donald John Trump the voice of one
tweeting out in the wilderness as
president Kofi phase critics continue to
wind up with egg on their face and his
own assertions keep asserting themselves
in reality it's time to ask has anybody
else noticed that Donald Trump has an
eerie ability to predict the future we
will explain what that's all about
then we will try to predict the future
in November in America in Ireland for
the Catholic Church a lot of predictions
going on prognostication will abound
finally some very good news on the
culture front we'll get into that later
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
and old show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have got so much to get to today
we've got we're gonna talk about
president Nostra Donald and his bizarre
ability to predict the future it is
actually pretty eerie but I think I have
a I have a theory on why that is the
case we will watch clips going all the
way back to the Comedy Central Roast of
Donald Trump back in 2011 nobody plays
these clips but it's they're very quite
prescient actually before we do that I
know what you're wondering how do I get
such a lovely shape how do I just get
such smooth soft skin like a baby's
bottom Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave
Club is so so good it is the best razor
I've ever used I love it I can't stop
talking about it
it delivers everything you need to look
feel and smell your best i i've talked
about these guys for a long time
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready in the bathroom I'll
raise ur first of all is is fabulous but
they'll give you dr. Carver's shave
butter and it's not like you know they
have that foamy stuff that it's like too
much or they have that little gel that's
like not for you know real burly men the
doctors Carver's shave butter are so so
good and they have they have everything
you need
they have shampoo they have conditioner
body wash tooth braced hair gel and they
have that thing it's really useful it's
very important in Europe they have
something called a bidet so when you're
using the facilities and taking care of
yourself you know everything gets
cleaned well what they offer is
something called a one wife Charlie's
I'll let you envision what that is very
effective here is a great way to save a
bunch to try a bunch of Dollar Shave
Club products right now and save a bunch
of money don't say I never did nothing
for you I got my wedding coming up I'm
giving you a wedding present for just
five bucks you can get their daily
essentials starter set it comes with a
body cleanser one wipe Charlies the
world-famous shave butter and the best
razor that they offer the six blade
executive it's the best razor I've ever
used keep the blades coming for a few
bucks more a month add in shampoo
toothpaste anything else that you need
in the bathroom don't have to worry
about going down to the drugstore or
what I usually do
letting the blades rust over for six
months and then I'm basically just using
pure rust to shave my face don't be that
guy let Dollar Shave Club make it easy
check it all out
dollarshaveclub.com /co FFA co v fe fe
dollarshaveclub.com / co FFA you know
predicting the future it's been on my
mind a lot recently I'm about to head
out to New York I'm gonna be there
getting ready for my wedding I've got my
bachelor party coming up this weekend so
if you don't see me next week or any
other time in the future you know I'm
sorry I had too much fun at my bachelor
party not a bad way to go at but I'm
thinking about the future a lot and have
you noticed this I have actually noticed
this over the past nine months
Donald Trump has this weird ability to
predict the future or at least it seems
like he's predicting the future and it's
much more pronounced because all of his
opponents have a total lack of ability
to predict the future in fact all of
their predictions do not come true they
make these totally insane predictions
these we're certain it's definitely
going to happen
Trump can't win 99% sure no there's
gonna and then none of them come true
and what Trump says which we all say is
crazy at the time that seems to happen
here's just a little reminder from Nancy
Pelosi Democrats talk about the Spill
often in very apocalyptic terms but
isn't really what's going on is that
many people are getting a very modest
tax cut and some people are getting a
tax increase while a lot of this is also
going to business but it's not the end
of the world no it is the end of this
healthcare the debate on health care is
life death this is Armageddon this is a
very big deal no this is Armageddon no
this no let me do it is the end of the
world I don't want to
so that was Nancy Pelosi and okay so now
we've lived through it because the
trouble with predictions this happens in
political predictions and in sports
predictions is these guys they go on TV
Nancy Pelosi gets up there in front of
the cameras and they make their
predictions and then they don't come
true and then we keep listening to them
for some reason so we got you know Nancy
Pelosi says this is Armageddon and yet
we still listen to her we still believe
her we still give her the floor and it
isn't just Nancy Pelosi Paul Krugman
predicted that the markets would plunge
if Trump won the election what have you
said the markets are going to plunge
what happened
Trump won the election the markets
Rose why don't we do we even handle this
in sports and sports they say this is no
this could never happen then it happens
and we keep listening to them the next
day there's a Bloomberg headline from
2016 the headline with Citigroup says a
Trump victory in November could cause a
global recession what happened not only
was there not a global recession but the
global economy rose in fact the IMF gave
credit to Donald Trump for that jump in
the global economy okay we still read
Bloomberg though we still listen to
Citigroup Politico predicted quote Wall
Street is set up for a major crash if
Donald Trump shocks the world on
election day and wins the White House
major crash' just didn't happen and they
weren't set up for a major crash because
the markets rose MIT Romney MIT Rosso
it's not just these crazy lefties MIT's
MIT Romney who's at least nominally a
Republican I know he invented Obamacare
and he spends most of his time
criticizing the effective conservative
Republican president but you know he's
nominally at least a Republican he said
Donald Trump's domestic policies would
lead to recession what's happened we've
we've had one of the greatest bull
market runs in history that happened
last year none of the experts predicted
it but that's exactly what happened six
trillion dollars worth of wealth created
particularly for the 55 million
Americans with 401k plans the the other
25 million Americans who have IRAs 20
million who have company pensions stock
ownership plans and for virtually
everybody else because of tax reform so
even if you're not among the many many
many millions of people who have some
stake in the market first of all you do
because the you're in the economy but
also because of tax reform everybody is
rising the median a household income
rose
pretty significantly within the last
year that's the median household income
that just reported very recently we were
told by Donald Trump's economists and by
Donald Trump himself we'll we won't see
3 percent economic growth anymore those
are the old days now we have the new
normal it can't happen what happened
under Donald Trump we got we saw greater
than 3% economic growth and it isn't
just on these election predictions
Donald Trump came out and said
that ms-13 they're animals that that
awful gang that kills children rapes
people there their motto is something
like kill rape control so maybe there's
some other permutation of those three
but that's their motto right I said
those guys are animals and the left said
they're not animals there people have
dare you they start defending ms-13 not
one week later an ms-13 member named
animal is sentenced to 40 years in a
federal prison for murdering a 15 year
old boy this seems a little weird
doesn't it yes I think the whole thing
is about animal and then not a week
later the guys name is animal that's his
street name and he goes to prison for 40
years
you saw this Donald Trump was talking
about during the campaign the building a
border wall and all those awful
criminals coming over from the Mexican
side of the the US border and they said
how you couldn't what are you talking
about there's no crime there's no crime
and then the k-t Steinle incident
erupted right after that he seems to
just be able to predict one step ahead
see exactly what's happening right in
the future in 2013 Donald Trump tweeted
out what Weiner is gone Spitzer is gone
next will be lightweight Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman is he a crook
he's worse than Spitzer or Weiner so he
tweets that and I don't know people say
what's new Schneiderman who care what
are we worried about Schneiderman just
five years later this happened a couple
weeks ago Eric Schneiderman was forced
to resign within hours after allegations
came out from multiple women that he
abused them sexually in the throes of
sex he got drunk and was battering them
and hitting them this is a guy he was a
full-throated me too supporter right
nobody could have expected who could
have predicted this wonderful feminist
this great Democrat politician in New
York was actually beating women against
their will when he got a little too
drunk in New York who predicted it
Donald Trump did how on earth does
president cough fa the voice of one
tweeting in the wilderness
how does he predict all of these things
go back even further don't even worry
about 2013 1987 Donald Trump took out a
full-page ad in The New York Times it
said there's nothing wrong with
America's foreign defense policy that a
little backbone
Cure now it seemed like he was taking a
shot at the Reagan administration here
and you got to say we did win the Cold
War so I don't know that's if that is
exactly the best way to read that but
the statement taken on its own is true
there's nothing wrong with a little with
America's foreign policy that a little
backbone can't cure and we look around
and we see that in action he did this to
Iran he did this to Korea and experts
have lost their minds when he said to
North Korea a little rocket man is short
and fat and I've got a button on my desk
with nuclear weapons and mine works when
he said that the experts lost their mind
they said he's belligerent he's
bellicose he's gonna throw us into World
War 3 if he rips up the Iran deal we're
gonna go into World War 3 it's certain
to happen I have a PhD and I wear a tie
and my glasses are horn room you have to
believe me it's gonna cause the end of
the world here you just see a little bit
from what the mainstream media said when
he did all of those things the most
important political news of the weekend
and today also happens to be the most
important news in the world because it's
about nothing less than World War three
and this news doesn't come from some
conspiracy theory website this news
comes from the chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee Republican
senator bob Corker senator corker
shocked Washington yesterday by saying
what virtually everyone in Washington
was thinking which is always always the
best way to shock Washington by saying
something that everyone is thinking but
not saying I can't I don't even know
where to begin with how wrong that is
but just to begin just first nobody in
Washington has ever thought anything
without saying it the most dangerous
place on planet earth is between
Washington politicians and a TV camera
none of them are having these grand
thoughts and not saying them they're
Craven they're crass and their publicity
hounds so that's to begin most people in
DC say things without thinking at all
that does happen people will say things
without thinking about them they won't
think things without saying but
everybody is thinking this everybody's
that look everybody is saying and that
just take lawrence O'Donnell
his own points everybody's saying that
we're going to have World War three
everybody's thinking at all of the smart
people all the people in ties who have
really strong jaws and comb their hair
the right way and that you know they
wear ties on camera they're all and they
go on TV sometimes they're all saying it
so it has to be true except that they're
all wrong
except it turned out they're all wrong
we will get to even more of this in one
second before that though visit this
ties in beautifully actually because
sometimes we need to get advice we need
to get advice from people who actually
know what they're talking about not
people who pretend to know what they're
talking about people who actually know
what they're talking about when you're
dealing with a real head-scratcher
having your go to person on call is a no
brainer this is especially true business
that's why I've got to tell you about
software advice a new sponsor the fact
that they're a new sponsor is just
enough that you should go help them out
right now software advice.com slash
knowles can or wles go over there and
they will help you out right now this is
a great opportunity especially if you
run a business if you have a small
business when it comes to picking the
right software for your business
software advice has done all of the
research for you their team of advisors
can point you in the right direction you
can start working more effectively right
away I've seen this up and involved in
many small businesses and when you get
started you think oh what there's so
many different software clients I can
use should I do this or this what's
better about this what should I do this
I've got to set up my team I've got to
get them working I'm wasting time time
is money watch okay I'm gonna spend two
months researching this or that I didn't
know forget it forget it these guys make
it so simple they make it ready for you
you're gonna save time you're gonna save
money go to software advice.com slash
knowles K&I wles
answer a few short questions about your
business you'll be connected with an
advisor to discuss the best software
options for your needs talking to an
advisor takes ten minutes or less
whether you're a medical professional or
a construction worker or you're an HR
pro or any other kind of business
you name it software advice will save
you time and help you make a more
informed decision and the software
struggle today go to software advice.com
slash knowles to get started get started
right now software in advice.com slash
knowles talk to an advisor for free it's
my wedding I keep giving things away
software advice.com / Knowles okay
so all those guys those unfortunately
those people didn't talk to software
advice they didn't talk to anybody who
had good advice
they just consulted their own empty
brains you know their own just rattling
around in their heads so they got that
wrong how about let's pull it back
forward to 2018 just this Russia
investigation all of the nonsense and
the lies and the fake news and the bad
predictions how many times have you
turned into the news you've tuned in and
they've said this is it for Trump now we
got him now now we got him weep Michael
Flynn had lunch he had borscht for lunch
so now we got Trump you know stormy
Daniels a porn store a currently working
porn star who has admitted to lying
publicly in official documents and has
been a Democrat operative for years and
tried to run for the Senate as a
Democrat and is an acknowledged and
admitted public liar
stormy Daniel says something they got
Trump they got him now they've got him
now and then the betting they never have
Trump do you notice that they always say
that we're gonna get him and then it
never happens does it uh and on all of
this
it seems that Donald Trump has been
right the whole time Donald Trump has
been right the whole time Obama and his
bureaucratic Crohn's have been caught
lying multiple times Donald Trump said
that Barack Obama wiretapped his
campaign and I'd like to eat okay so he
said we've been wiretapped when he
tweeted it
he used quotation marks wiretapped the
importance of this is that it shows as
Donald Trump
usually does when he speaks he can speak
using metonym or synecdoche or many
literary devices that perhaps he's
unaware he's using but he even used that
phrase because I don't think Donald
Trump was alleging that Barack Obama
personally went into Trump Tower and
installed a little device on his actual
telephone right nobody thinks that
that's what Donald Trump was saying but
all of the people who want to prove
Trump wrong even though Trump was right
they say well he didn't wiretap him said
right well Donald Trump also said Obama
did it
does anyone doesn't even think Donald
Trump
actually alleged Barack Obama broke into
Trump Tower no he's speaking
metaphorically and using metonym z' and
the Obama administration did surveil his
campaign
they didn't just surveil some aides
although they did surveil aides but they
surveilled the head of his campaign that
the chairman of his campaign this is
what we heard when this came out this is
from the FBI quote with respect to the
president's tweets about alleged
wiretapping directed at him by the prior
administration I have no information
that supports those tweets and we have
looked carefully inside the FBI the
Department of Justice has asked me to
share with you that the answer is the
same for the Department of Justice and
all its components the department has no
information that supports those tweets
that's what we heard right except that's
not true we later learned that Barack
Obama was directly surveillance
administration was directly surveilling
the Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort
and likely picked up the calls of the
President himself how about now cuz the
big story in the news is the deep State
gunning for Trump and what does this
mean does this mean that there's some
guy with a mustache twirling his
mustache around sitting at the FBI some
regular agent who's doing his job and
just trying to protect the country of
course not that's not what that means
but what it does mean is there is
bureaucratic creep here there is
political creep we know that Barack
Obama weaponized the federal government
and the bureaucracy to attack his
political opponents I'm a member of an
organization that was the victim of this
oh so is it really so crazy to suggest
that there was a White House influence
on the FBI in these investigations as a
matter of fact we know from the leaked
Peter struck texts that the White House
was running the investigation right that
was one now if even if that's
contradicted later we have that coming
out that the White House is influencing
these investigations we went through the
timeline a bit yesterday The Wall Street
Journal lays it out very well the FBI
claims that they didn't open up the
probe into donald trump and russia
collusion or whatever until july 31st
2016 now that was the claim and donald
trump came and he said BS i don't
believe it all the smart people said you
have to believe the FBI come on you have
to believe you can't believe Donald
Trump he's a crazy guy so then the New
York Times reports on Friday the FBI's
top secret informant Steven Halper met
with Donald Trump aide quarter-page only
after a July 31st launch of the probe
see keeps the FBI's timeline see it
keeps the Obama administration timeline
the Washington Post went further in
their flacking they said nah hopper and
Paige didn't meet until August 31st
until early September they didn't know
well into that probe now quarter-page
says something different Carter Paige
says that he met with the FBI informant
helper in mid-july early to mid July and
we know this actually happened because
it occurred at a very public symposium
at Cambridge University in the UK Paige
further says that he was invited to that
symposium at the end of May end of May
or early June ok now I know that this is
one reason by the way why people aren't
talking about this too extensively on
the news is it's kind of hard to wrap
your head around there are so many
moving parts when you get into nefarious
politics that's what happens but Halper
the FBI informant was a central figure
in that symposium the quarter Paige was
invited to the symposium was titled 2016
s race to change the world another
central figure at that symposium was Sir
Richard Dearlove who spent four decades
working for British intelligence
mi6 he was the chief of mi6 from 1999 to
2004 so we've got an FBI informant who
worked in for the federal government and
for the intelligence agencies for
decades we then have a British
intelligence agent who'd worked for
decades that means that dear love by the
way worked with Christopher Steele who
ran the Russia desk for mi6 and compiled
the famous dossier that was funded by
Hillary Clinton and by the Democrats
whoa that's a lot of coincidences so
they all just coincidentally just hate
coincidentally they all invited this
Trump campaign aide to this symposium
before the Russia probe allegedly began
into Donald Trump and it's just a
coincidence probably right it's just a
that look sometimes decades-long
intelligence officers for multiple
countries sometimes they just invite
members of political campaigns who
they're surveilling to you know to
academic conferences in who knows and
then coincidentally two months later
they start surveilling him right that's
just what happens I don't know about
that now does this mean for sure that
Barack Obama was sitting there saying
we're gonna spy on Trump we're gonna
kill him we're gonna kill him no doesn't
mean that for sure we don't want to jump
the gun we want to be serious here
doesn't mean we should investigate yeah
I think we probably should investigate I
think that's probably a good idea
because now the left is denying it and
Scott Adams summed it up perfectly you
had a great tweet on all of this he
tweeted out quote four things to
understand about Spygate that's what
they're calling it number one there was
no spy in the Trump campaign number two
the spying that did not happen was
totally justified number three it would
be bad for national security to identify
the spy who doesn't exist number four
the spies name is stephane some of those
seem to you sure that that's basically
the argument from the left now it's
really hard to believe we'll see where
that investigation goes I will just say
though all the people who go on TV with
the ties and we win with the sharp we
know with my glasses basically there's
Rachel Maddow they go on and they give
the expert opinion they've been wrong
the whole time not only have they been
wrong we know that they've lied publicly
we know that they've lied on the record
we know that people from the
administration the Obama administration
of lied Donald Trump has a pretty good
track record here I don't know I don't
know which side I'd lean toward if I
were a gambling man which I am and I
have the check from Ben to prove it
probably put my bets on president Koch
that they and this will get back so we
have to answer this question how why is
it that Donald Trump a gigantic reality
TV star casino real estate mogul wins
the presidency on his first try how did
that guy why is he a prophet why Adam
that guy can predict the future but all
of the experts with PhDs can't predict
the future it all goes back well it goes
back further than this but it certainly
goes back to the 2011 Comedy Central
Roast of Donald Trump this is sort of a
long clip but it's really important and
people haven't dug this one up in a
while the
thing is so rich with clues as to why
Trump has succeeded in politics here it
is of the atrocities that we as a nation
must endure like the Jersey Shore a
[Applause]
piece of advice my greasy friend
you don't need to put all of that
product in your hair you just don't look
how great my hair looks and I don't use
anything and it looks very good what's
the difference between a wet raccoon and
Donald J Trump's hair a wet raccoon
doesn't have 7 billion dollars in the
bag
very funny very funny America is going
through tough times and we all need to
laugh true I know that better days are
ahead if we believe in ourselves and the
way I believe in myself and I really do
believe in myself then come June if I
decide to run you'll have the great
pleasure of voting for the man that will
easily go down as the greatest president
in the history of the United States me
Donald John Trump god bless america
and good night there is so much you
there there this was not in 2015 even
this was not before this look recent run
this was in 2011 this isn't because he
was considering running in 2012 and I
actually just remembered this he said in
some interview might have been as part
of this roast he said at the time he
said you know if I choose to run for
president I'm gonna do a lot better and
all you people think I'm gonna do and we
all you know we all laughed at him at
the time that thought President Donald
Trump that was a joke right it was a
joke in movies people joked about it as
a punchline and there's so much here
there's so much political skill and
that's I think why he seems like he can
predict the future you know he's having
fun he's joking around with the
celebrities who were on the dais there
are a lot of celebrities on the dais
there's Snoop Dogg the family guy guy
Seth MacFarlane Lisa Lampanelli a ton of
people the Jersey Shore guy Mike the
situation and he's there and he's joking
around and they're joking around with
him because in those days it was okay to
joke around with Donald Trump it wasn't
you know now you're not allowed to if
you're a Hollywood celebrity now you
have to pretend you hate him but you
know until five minutes ago all of
Hollywood loved this guy he was a king
of Hollywood so he goes out there and
some good lines you had a line about
Snoop Dogg he said some nuke dog is a do
rags to riches story yeah line about
Lisa Lampanelli she's a comedian who's
old joke about her is that she's not the
not the most spell to last in the world
who know she is not terribly thin and so
people make fat jokes about her and she
loved it she's laughing clapping you
know that was all nice he's making jokes
about the other people have their basic
cable hacks you know talentless people
and he's this big star also true in some
ways about certain people up there and
but what we see here is he jokes about
himself easily he jokes about you know
people say that he can't joke about
himself Donald Trump can't take a joke
that isn't true at all
they say Donald Trump is a narcissist
you know like like Barack Obama's a
narcissist no way no way I mean does
Donald Trump have an ego yeah Trump has
an ego I don't think anyway he's denying
that but is he narcissist no and here's
the difference an egotist hard-charging
puts his name on building says his name
a lot gets it out there pushes back
won't you know won't take the hits he's
gonna go he's gonna punch right if he if
he takes a joke he's gonna give that
joke right back what the narcissist does
is he takes it so personally with Donald
Trump I don't think it's personal I
don't think he takes I don't think he
goes home and cries he says well he
didn't like me or he gets really angry
says though they didn't they I'm gonna
get him back
oh man no I don't think it's that at all
I think he has a great ability to
compartmentalize to abstract himself
from situations and that's why he has
some pretty cold thinking because it
can't be both right he can't be coldly
strategic and this angry narcissist
Barack Obama seems like a narcissist I
mean he wrote two books about his
favorite subject by the time he was in
his 20s or something like that or I
think the second memoir came in is 30s
that there is a certain narcissism there
it's the difference I suppose is that
Donald Trump writes his own press
releases and Barack Obama believes his
own press releases and those are two
different things you can even see it you
see it in the way that Donald Trump
talks so he leans into the money thing
he's always talking about how much money
he has you know the difference is the
hair the the wet raccoon or whatever he
says isn't worth seven billion dollars
but he pushes you past the sale when he
talks he says if I run you will have the
pleasure of voting
for the greatest president in the
history of the United States and what he
does this is another thing Scott Adam
says as mentioned though not on this
particular point just the category
Donald Trump pushes you past the sale so
instead of saying I'm gonna win the
presidency okay he said that you say no
you won't but he says I will be not only
will I be the president I will be the
greatest president not just in the
recent years I will be the greatest
president in the history of the country
not only that you will have the you will
have pleasure voting for me it will be a
pleasure to vote for me and the reason
you do this it's the same reason Trump
talks about the wall and he says Mexico
is gonna pay for the wall he says it not
because Mexico is gonna pay for the wall
who cares if Mexico pays for the wall
it's not that expensive what he's doing
is he's establishing in your mind that
the wall will be built the wall is going
to be built and so that's not up for
debate all that's up for debate is who's
gonna pay for it I will be the president
that's not up for debate
all that's up for debate is will I be
the greatest president in American
history or just the greatest president
in the last twenty years or something
right that's what he's pushed I will be
the president the only question is are
you gonna have pleasure voting for me or
great pleasure voting for me right he
does this it's a really strong tactic of
his and by the way he did better at this
roast than most of the other performers
cuz he's funnier because he's more in
the culture the other guys were funny I
don't mean to denigrate them I'm not I
don't wanna be a hack here they are
funny people Seth MacFarlane's very
funny guy
Snoop Dogg actually was pretty funny
Mike the situation wasn't you know it's
not his strong suit but but a lot of
them were funny but Trump was better why
because people relate to Trump and
because Trump knew his people he talks
about this he said one of the secrets to
my success is I really know people I'm a
people person so I think here we have
the answer to our question can Trump
actually predict the future as he
plugged in to you know the cosmos and
the natural order of the universe I
don't know about that but why does it
seem like he can predict the future it's
because he can put his finger on the
pulse of the culture he knows people he
talks to people he's not isolated he
doesn't live in a little bubble in DC he
doesn't just go to lunches at the
Brookings
institution and talk about how sad it is
that people don't hold their champagne
glass in the right way anymore it's why
he's a good salesman
I mean he's the greatest salesman in the
modern era he is all sales right he
sells everything he sold his he sold
real estate and he made incredible deals
on real estate in New York
basically by just tricking the media but
you know it's great in that book I just
read by Conrad Black Lord Conrad Black
Donald J Trump a president like no other
we had him on the show this week I guess
this week or last week he talks about
how when he put the Commodore deal
together he just did it by sheer tyranny
of will he knows people he knew how the
city would react to this how the state
the this company would react to this how
the media would react to this and he
just put it all together and he did it
he's totally in the culture so he can
shape the culture this is why Andrew
Breitbart was right he's if he's in the
culture if Donald Trump is in the
culture means Donald Trump is in the
present most people are living in the
past
most people are fighting the last war
especially in politics people who are
living in the past think people who are
living in the present or seeing the
future
most people are fighting the Mitt Romney
campaign by the way now people are
fighting the 2016 race they're trying to
fight the 2016 race in 2020 2020 is
gonna be different and you're gonna see
this all over again you're gonna see
it's gonna look like Donald Trump's
predicting the future again it's not cuz
he is predicting the future it's because
he's living in the present I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube we
have a ton more to get to you cannot
miss it very important points look I'm
gonna be gone for a week on my honeymoon
so I got to give you all the good cough
effe now otherwise Ben is gonna just
depress everybody and he's gonna say
like things aren't that great
he doesn't snort nearly as much cofee as
I do so you're gonna want you know at
least at least you'll have Clavin to say
that everything is tickety-boo but we
got to get all that cough fao right now
if you're on the Le wire comm thank you
you helped us keep the lights on you
keep Kofi Fae in my cup and I'm gonna
bring this cup to the beach on my
honeymoon and I'm gonna probably get
arrested for that but I need it cuz
you're not allowed to drink open
containers of cough f/a on the beach
that's not a lads against the law you
got to put it in the appropriate
fda-approved vessel for leftist tiers so
what do you get it's $10 a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the end of Clevenger you get the
bench up here
you can't ask questions in the mailbag
as there are questions in the
conversation you should get your
questions in for this final no not final
I have one more before my wedding but
penultimate pre-wedding mailbag I'm
probably gonna be asking you questions
that's what I really need you won't get
this because none of that other stuff
matters this matters the leftist tears
tumblr because every time Nostra Donald
predicts the future every time our great
prophet the one tweeting out in the
wilderness predicts the future the tears
are going to flow and you're going to
need this vessel go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
all right we're back and I'm glad I'm
kind of glad we put this one behind the
paywall because I have to criticize Bill
Kristol and I really like Bill Kristol
personally yeah bill kristol was a
professor of mine for a summer in DC and
I like him very much person he's a very
nice guy these tweets though these you
know I've held off long enough these
tweets bill kristol tweeted the other
day said quote one striking contrast
between reagan and trump reagan's
conservatism was a youthful movement in
spirit and often in fact fueled by
hopefulness for the future
Trump's conservatism is a reactionary
movement of older Americans fueled by
anger and fear you know I've always been
an old soul I guess I guess I've always
been an old so Kanye West maybe is very
old too maybe Kandice oh and mr. Charlie
Kirk or they all hold all that all of
the YouTube people who are they all
really old is that it I don't think so I
don't think that's true at all in fact I
think the oldest trump supporter I know
is Andrew Clavin and he behaves like a
younger man than I do you know the the
latest I ever stay out when I go out at
night is when I'm hanging out with Drew
the Trump movement is a youthful
movement it's energized and it's
exuberant Donald Trump one more
Millennials than John McCain or Mitt
Romney and Donald Trump did just fine
with the Utes you know I worry I fear
without descending into psychobabble
that Bill Kristol might be projecting
here angry old fearful I don't know does
that describe Kanye West or does that
describe president Trump's detractors
Ronald Reagan's movement was youthful
that's absolutely true Ronald Reagan's
movement happened almost 40 years ago
well it really had happened over 40
years ago because it began in the 60s
and 70s now the Ronald Reagan movement
is older it's older now we need
something new Ronald Reagan solved the
problems of his time he did his part he
kept the faith that's what he said when
he said farewell to Americans he said we
did it let them say of us we did it we
kept the faith we did our part we can't
dig up the body of Ronald Reagan and
have him become the head of the
Republican Party and the present
again you can't exhume poor Gipper
Gipper did a good job let him rest let
him have his eternal reward now we're
dealing with something new we're dealing
with something new and a reactionary
movement of older Americans fueled by
anger and fear oppose him but that's
that's no legitimate reason the the
remaining antitrump
right is living in a fantasy world one
because it barely exists anymore of all
of the the more prominent Trump critics
on the right
we had been was one during the campaign
certainly he was always the most
reasonable about this it kills me to be
too complimentary toward the big boss on
the show but he was always the most
reasonable he put that Magga hat on the
day that Trump nominated Gorsuch right
he wore that maggot but even some of the
holdouts the people who have still just
really were constantly negative toward
Trump Jonah Goldberg said the other day
that he would vote for Donald Trump that
was pretty good and look there's news
out today that I don't even want to tell
you about I actually do I've tried to
avoid talking about this on the show
because I don't want to jinx us I don't
want to jinx November bloomberg is
reporting that the blue wave may be
dissipating the headline today is
Democrats prep for battle not surfing a
blue wave remember though all those
really smart guys in suits with glasses
on TV and they go on TV so you know you
have to believe them all those guys told
us it was gonna be a blue wave of
Republicans we're gonna lose the house
and the Senate and and Donald Trump was
gonna be kicked out of office and what
are we seeing now we're seeing maybe
there are some cracks now I don't want
to tell you don't tell anybody I know
that only the most you know the the
fringe East most extreme people of the
vast right-wing conspiracy tune in here
so I feel like I can tell you guys but
don't tell anybody else historically
speaking we should lose this election in
November the Republicans should lose the
house if not the Senate also I don't
know if that's what we see on the ground
I don't know if that's what we see on
the culture because everything's getting
better I don't tell them that because
conservatives have to go out for us to
win it so don't tell anybody but I dare
I say I'm hopeful things are looking
good right now so you know that's not an
excuse to to go ahead and do battle in
November but things are looking so good
even Glenn Beck
was a big he was a big anti-trump he was
a trump critic for a long time
I love Glenn Beck Glenn Beck this is
such a beautiful day he came around
here's the video enjoy here's why I'm
predicting a 2020 win when I saw
yesterday the how the press was all
reporting the same damn story that
Donald Trump was calling ms-13 gang
members they left that out of the story
animals and they were spinning it as if
he was saying that about all immigrants
I'd had enough I have enough media if
you can get me Glenn back to do this
there it is and in case you're only
listening to us on radio I just donned a
red make America great again if you can
drive me to the point to where I say you
know what I've had enough I'll vote for
him in 2020 gladly I'll vote for him in
2020 and not really even on his record
which we'll talk about here in a second
is pretty damn amazing pretty damn
amazing yes that is that video is pretty
damn amazing I love it
I love it because it where is it the
anti-trump right is basically just gone
now it's basically over save for a few
tweets the remaining anti Trump stuff on
the right and and even largely on the
left it comes from fantasy and this is
the cultural side of things we have to
get to this in the last five minutes
here a spell has been broken the
cultural hypnosis has cracked to use the
phrase of Kanye West the consciousness
has shifted here's an example Kendrick
Lamar Kendrick Lamar is some popular
musician I take it I'm using those words
loosely he invited a white fan on stage
at one of his concerts he asked her to
sing his song then he decided to
publicly shame her for singing the
lyrics which he wrote here's the clip
lady
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's there when we started
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's it is painful to watch cuz it was
obviously a setup I mean it's just
ridiculous
do you see she goes she's having fun she
thinks she's still in it right in she
goes I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't know
I'm sorry I didn't mean to be so
disrespectful to his fans he put the
words in the song it's like every third
word in his songs by the way he won the
Pulitzer Prize for Literature he won the
Pulitzer Prize I just that's that's what
happened in recent years that's what's
happened to our culture that's a sidebar
Hey it's outrageous it's ridiculous you
look up there and you see you just feel
so bad for her he invites her onstage he
says sing the lyrics that I wrote and
then she sings the lyrics that he wrote
and then he calls her a racist basically
and publicly shame sir so so wrong even
Whoopi Goldberg agrees on this by the
way Whoopi Goldberg on the view and I
don't look to the view for wisdom but
Whoopi Goldberg on the view said that's
ridiculous was wrong for him to do it he
shouldn't have done it
and you know what most people agree with
her and with that opinion there are two
explanations that we could believe for
why and how that woman sang the the
n-word in this song here's one
explanation this is this is crazy as my
conspiracy theory that he wrote the
lyrics and asked her to sing them yeah
that's my crazy conspiracy theory the
other one is that she hates black people
it's got to be that right but nobody
actually thinks that nobody thinks that
this woman has Animists for black people
and that's why he's getting that flack I
you know the it's really really
ridiculous we have so many so little
racial animus today that we have to
invent it we actually get there's so
little racial animus that we just have
to make it up at a pole cloth it's just
a fantasy
this ties in with our theme of Trump
predicting everything because the NFL
has now banned kneeling for the flag in
the national anthem this was another one
you know people were doing it and they
were they were banning the flag or that
they were kneeling for the flag and they
were saying
because racism is so awful in America
we're going to disrespect the American
flag so there's a lot to deal with there
there's al I don't know if I agree with
this or that or that that's crazy but
you certainly wouldn't disrespect the
flag which gives you the right to
protest which gives you the right to
self-government
so NFL now has banned kneeling for the
flag by the way it was already banned in
the game operations manual which existed
long before this hullabaloo the game
operations manual for the NFL read the
national anthem must be played prior to
every NFL game and all players must be
on the sidelines for the national anthem
during the national anthem players on
the field and bench area should stand at
attention face the flag hold helmets in
their left hand refrain from talking
the home team should ensure the flag is
in good condition it should be pointed
out to players and coaches we continue
to be judged by the public in this area
of respect for the flag and our country
failure to be on the field by the start
of the anthem may result in disciplines
such as fine suspensions and forfeiture
of draft choice for violations of the
above including the first offense it was
announced today teams will be fined by
the league if players go on the field
and kneel now they're letting them stay
in the locker room if they really want
to but if they go and kneel they'll be
fined by the league this is all this
isn't about the great patriotism of the
NFL I don't know that they care at all
about the country this is about money
and this is about reality and Donald
Trump there's a lot about both of those
things and brags have betted a lot you
know the the kneeling thing started a
couple years ago it really took off last
year what happened the NFL ratings
tanked the 2017 audience was almost 10
percent down over the 2016 season
Trump brought the issue to a head why
because he's nostra Donald or because
he's living in the present he sees
what's happening in the culture he was
really strong on this issue so now but
in our last couple minutes here I'm
gonna get to some predictions for the
future that don't involve Trump or NFL
players or Kendrick Lamar or Nancy
Pelosi or any of that these are
predictions that we're seeing over in
Ireland they've been big news items on
Friday Ireland is gonna vote on a
referendum to repeal the eighth
amendment to ban abortion Ireland is a
strong Catholic country it's got some of
the strictest abortion laws in the world
and there's a vote now to possibly ban
it now by the way if you want an
abortion in Ireland you just go to
England and you get one
and that's that's what people do but
it's a strong Catholic country this is
being called the end of Catholicism in
that country the poles are too close to
call
it's we're not really sure there's been
momentum on the side of pro-life
hopefully pro-life will eat get out but
to call it the end of Catholicism is a
little crazy I was talking with our
colleague here Paul Cardinal Bois about
this earlier Ireland rejected its strict
Catholicism a few years ago when it
voted to redefine marriage to redefine
marriage to include same-sex gay unions
and so that's a question whereas Ireland
going what is Ireland is it a Catholic
country is it something new this brings
us to the Pope the big headline this
week as the Pope is okay with being gay
or something I was with the popular
media were reporting because he told a
victim of Chilean sexual abuse Juan
Carlos Cruz that God loves him this was
reported by the media as the Pope says
it's totally cool to do a lot of gay
stuff now Pope loves gay sex beibei's
was the headline and it's a little more
nuanced than that
they thought it was shocking that the
Pope would tell a gay man that God loves
him as though this were breaking with
Catholic tradition as though previously
the Catholic doctrine was God hates gay
people when that has never been that has
never once been the Catholic dogma or a
doctrine at all God loves you God loves
you if you're if you have any sort of
assortment of proclivities in your mind
God still loves you you know the old man
has fallen people do many worse things
then wink at the cute fella down the bar
you know there's a deception and fraud
and all of this God still loves you just
don't want you to turn to him and do the
right thing the culture is very confused
and so where's the prediction coming
where's the living in the present to
seem like we're predicting the future
the Catholic Church will either hold
true to its divine institution to it to
the Gospels to the sacred tradition or
it would fade away that's it it won't it
won't become some sort of Protestant
Church and it won't like so many
mainline churches here won't say okay
but now we're gonna change this piece of
2000 year old doctrine
no it'll defend its doctrine and its
truth or it will disappear Ireland will
be Ireland it
we'll be Catholic Ireland the land you
know the beautiful old Ireland or
Ireland will cease to exist and
something new will happen but Ireland
will be Ireland or will cease to exist
the cultural argument of all of trumps
talk about globalism and nationalism
that this is what that gets to this is
what it all is but think of the brexit
Britain will be Britain or there won't
be a Britain there will be said there
will just be a big blobby EU Britain
will be Britain or there won't be a
Britain Americans will salute our flag
and defend our country or they won't
have a country we won't have a country
Trump said this on the trail he said we
will we either have a country or we
don't have a country
Irving Kristol said this in 93 a quitter
Irving Kristol bill Crystal's father
said conservative thought is religion
nationalism and economic growth the
foundations of civilization religion
nationalism and of course economic
growth it has to grow it has to advance
or it'll wither away and die the
foundations of civilization are worth
conserving those are the sure
predictions those are the only sure I'm
not as good as Nostra Donald so I know
that's all I can predict for sure we
will defend our countries in our faiths
or we won't have any countries or faiths
to defend that's it I'll leave it to the
other prophets who tweet out in the
wilderness to predict which one that
will be but it is up to us and for that
I am hopeful okay and I know you know I
get all I'm thinking about the future a
lot these days folks send in your
questions to the mailbag we will be back
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you them
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you